here's what would happen if we sent our  trash to the Sun  this scorching ball could obliterate any  Trash we throw at it but getting it to  the Sun would require over  168 million Rockets a year it would cost  over 33 trillion dollars just to get  those Rockets into Earth's orbit  it's a lot cheaper to start going waste  free now I got this from morning Brew  morning Brew is a free daily newsletter  that comes to your inbox Monday through  Sunday in just five minutes catch up on  all the business finance and Tech news  that over 4 million people are reading  through morning Brew it's free to sign  up just click on the link in the  comments you'll get access to the most  exciting stories of the Day stories like